[Musik]
es sind aufmerksame blicke tief hinein
in die schwarze nacht blicke die leben
retten können gefilmt mit einer
infrarotkamera
wir haben ein gummiboot gesichtet mit
flüchtlingen gummiboot das ist immer
schwierig man weiß nie in welchem
zustand sind
ein französisch britisches reporterteam
ist ende letzten jahres mit dabei als
die ocean viking crew das rettungsboot
zu wasser lässt
es ist eine gefährliche aktion immer
wieder werden helfer auf hoher see
beschossen
nach zehn minuten fahrt finden sie die
plastic nussschale auf ihr dutzende von
menschen menschen in großer angst in
panik
[Musik]
sie müssen jetzt unbedingt tun was ich
ihnen sage in diesem moment rettet die
rutschen biking crew menschen leben das
von männern frauen und kinder
so einfach ist das woher sie kommen wer
sie sind was sie auf das boot trieb
all das spielt für die helfer keine
rolle
[Musik]
gott beschütze sie sie haben mein leben
gerettet
erschöpft aber glücklich
niemand ist ins wasser gefallen alle
überleben diesen moment
an bord kommt auch emanuel aus kamerun
auf socken mit schmerzenden augen
die schiffs ärzte versorgen ihn die
erleichterung ist groß
ohne das team von sos méditerranée und
ärzte ohne grenzen wären diese menschen
vermutlich gestorben
auf hoher see im mittelmeer vor der
küste europas eine rettungsoperation
unter diesen bedingungen so erfolgreich
durchzuführen ohne verluste das ist ein
kleines wunder
die ocean viking eines von vielen
rettungsschiffe finanziert hauptsächlich
durch spenden unterwegs auf dem
mittelmeer der flüchtlings route nach
europa die inzwischen zum massengrab
geworden ist tango ist rettungs
koordinator an bord er erfährt jeden tag
jede nacht wie es um europas
migrationspolitik bestellt ist wie es um
das schicksal von menschen steht die
nichts haben außer der kleidung am
leiden meine großeltern haben mir immer
gesagt auf dem meer gibt es eines was
über allem anderen steht die solidarität
ich habe so viele tote gesehen so viele
leichen
sie alle haben wenig gemein sind
christen muslime afrikaner asiaten ein
schicksal allerdings teilen sie sie alle
sind in libyen aufgebrochen der hölle
auf erden wie sie sagen wer von dort
nach europa will hat meist
unvorstellbares erlebt es sind menschen
die lieber im meer ertrinken als länger
dort zu bleiben
[Musik]
darf ich mal fühlen
eine junge frau 24 jahre schwanger im
sechsten monat
auch sie kam auf einem gummiboot aus
libyen darf ich sie fragen diese
schwangerschaft ist die entstanden weil
ihnen gewalt angetan wurde
nein und das ist okay freuen sie sich
[Musik]
das geht vorbei die frauen an bord
sprechen nicht viel über libyen über die
flüchtlingslager dort eine aber äußert
sich die polizisten dort die bedienen
sich haifa meistens suchen sie sich die
jüngsten mädchen raus sie gehen in den
nachbarraum und schlafen dort mit ihnen
einfach nebenan
auch emanuel inzwischen wieder bei
kräften öffnet sich erzählt vom wahnsinn
in libyschen camps die nehmen deine
hände und legen sie so auf den boden
dann holt eine einen prügel raus und
schlägt ihr auf den finger er bricht dir
die finger
sie schlugen uns zu jeder tageszeit
morgens und abends morgens und am
rettungskorb die nato tank weiß von der
hölle die die flüchtlinge erleben in
nordafrika in libyen besonders es ist
europas pakt mit dem teufel
denn die eu zahlt millionen von euro
unter anderem typische gruppen die sich
küstenwache nennen und die vor der küste
flüchtlinge einsammeln und sie
zurückbringen
aber umstritten sind die einsätze
durchaus sie seien das taxi nach europa
die seenotretter sie verstießen gegen
das seerecht drängen in hoheitsgewässer
ein widersetzten sich der armee für die
retter sind das keine schlagenden
argumente dem kamerateam gelingt es nach
tripolis zu reisen der umkämpften
hauptstadt eines landes das nach dem
sturz von langzeitherrscher duffy im
bürger
versinkt zwei regierungen und zwei
armeen ein land in totale anarchie hier
zu drehen ist lebensgefährlich
aber das team will wissen wie ist die
lage der flüchtlinge die hier stranden
die journalisten nehmen kontakt zu einem
lokalpolitiker auf der mann nennt sich
khaled verspricht sie in ein camp zu
führen
vorher aber sollen die reporter den
bürgermeister interview er habe eine
nachricht an europa illegale migration
ist eine katastrophe für libyen
unser land leidet darunter
es gibt tausende und abertausende
migranten hier und die regierung bezahlt
dafür mit geld das dem libyschen volk
gehört was der bürgermeister nicht sagt
seit 2017 hat die eu mehr als 90
millionen euro an libyen bezahlt khaled
nimmt das team tatsächlich mit in ein
camp der mann in uniform ist hier der
chef eine dubiose gestalt zu dessen
füßen hunderte von migranten sitzen und
schweigen weil journalisten da sind gibt
es instruktionen sag ihnen die wahrheit
sagt ihnen ihr seid hier sicher dass sie
alles bekommt was er braucht
wo dass sie euer geld behalten dürfen
allet führt die örtliche kirche vor
für unsere christlichen migranten sagt
er so gastfreundlich sei libyen
das zeigt unsere positive arbeit die wir
verrichten um diesen leuten hier zu
helfen
die menschen wollen ja einfach nur ihr
leben verbessern
schauen sie hier ist ein gläubiger
christ können sie hier frei ihrer
religion ausleben
ja das kann ich
wir haben diese kirche und das ist gut
für uns und dann das ein kurzer moment
der ablenkung khaled im gespräch mit dem
camp chef das team läuft los und dreht
mit versteckter kamera in einem
seitenbau flüchtlinge weisen den weg
zeigen den journalisten chaos müll
konfiszierte war völlig überfüllte
schlafräume leben auf dem fußboden
verschmutzte toiletten als einziger
zugang zu wasser kochen zwischen
schlafsäcken manche flüchtlinge leben
schon seit jahren hier
ich hatte heute den ganzen tag nur ein
trockenes brot kurz danach das team
fliegt aufprall at und der aufseher
verlangen dass die aufnahmen gelöscht
werden
das team muss raus aus dem camp libyen
ist vermutlich eines der schlimmsten
länder in dem man als flüchtling
stranden kann
es gibt hier keine sicherheit es ist
kein ort an dem man sicher ist oder an
dem man in frieden leben kannst zurück
auf der ocean viking zurück auf dem meer
wo sich das schiff seinen weg durch
einen sturm band und nicht nur emanuel
übel ist seit tagen schon kreuz die
ocean viking zwischen malta und italien
hin und her wartet auf eine anleger
erlaubnis denn das ist ein weiterer teil
des europäischen dramas sind die
menschen gerettet will sie kein land
aufnehmen
zermürbend ist das
dann endlich kommt sie die nachricht auf
die alle war erlaubnis erteilt das
schiff darf in italien anlegen
[Applaus]
was das reporterteam gedreht hat
wiederholt sich jeden tag aufs neue auf
dem mittelmeer europas badewanne
dort wo menschen urlaub machen und
andere den tod finden
[Musik]
ja ich bin erleichtert dass wir jetzt
anlegen können
aber eben nur für den moment beim
nächsten mal bei der nächsten tour kann
es schon wieder anders aus gerettet aus
seenot geflohen aus libyen angekommen in
europa ihre zukunft steht weiter in den
sternen
marseille einige wochen danach das
reporterteam trifft sich noch einmal mit
emanuel
er ist inzwischen in frankreich sie
wollen ihnen zeigen was sie mitgebracht
haben aus libyen in fragen ob sich seine
eindrücke mit ihren decken
als ich da war war diese seite für die
somalia reserviert ach ja ich kenne
diese große zelle wieder finanzen sie
den kosovo
die wi-fi im winter wird es da sehr kalt
weil es so ein großer raum ist da
schlagen sie dich da missbrauchen sie
dich da machen sie alles mit da haben
sie uns immer rein geholt
manchmal war außer mir nur eine andere
person in der sendung die wurde
misshandelt weil das so war haben wir
den raum den kosovo genannt und auch den
camp chef meint er wieder zu erkennen
das ist der bärtige ich kenne ihn mit
seinem scheinheiligen lachen wenn
hilfsorganisationen da sind dann ist er
immer sehr freundlich immer bla bla bla
aber wenn die weg sind kommt die hölle
zurück mich hat er nicht geschlagen
aber er hat eine frau ins gesicht
geschlagen die vor mir stand er sieht
sie erschlägt sie war im winter hat er
mal eine andere frau die ihr baby
eingeschlossen die frau hat in der zelle
ihr kind bekommen
die erinnerungen an seine peiniger an
den kosovo in libyen das knappe
überleben auf hoher see
die ungewisse zukunft all das tragen
flüchtlinge wie emanuel in ihr neues
leben
während europas flüchtlingspolitik schon
an den vereinbarten verteilungs quoten
scheitert während das mittelmeer längst
zum friedhof geworden ist und während
hilfsorganisationen weiter jeden tag
menschen leben rennen
[Musik]